i don't care what anybody thinks about  me so i'm willing to lose everything and  go back to a studio apartment with eight  family members and i could care less if  twitter blew up and said ha ha garyvee  you thought you were hot [ __ ] i just  don't care not because i'm cool because  it's just the way i was built i'm in my  own head in my own life i know who i am  and i don't do business for mercedes or  for a rolex i do it because it's my  oxygen i'm happier in the most pressure  business spots because i'm not in it for  anything else when you don't actually  care about people's judgment and when  you don't actually need money for fancy  [ __ ] to impress people  business is the best